tian belle game bahia ride est
journaliste et fondateur de la voie du
mahdi bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors on le sait
il ya une polémique après que deux
scientifiques français sur les plateaux
à télé au évoqué la possibilité de se
servir de l'afrique comme un terrain
d'essai un peu comme si les africains ça
veut dire est finalement de cobayes mais
là c'est différent l'afrique du sud
s'est porté volontaire pour ces essais
cliniques
oui vous n'avez pas fait quoi réseau
l'évoquant on se rappelle tout de même
que cette vive polémique à super le
continent certain moment donné suite à
l'intervention de deux éminences grises
de l'institut pasteur
mais ça reste une opinion largement
partagée de johannesbourg peut-être à
dakar dans la mentalité des africains
dans la conscience collective que ces
essais sont plutôt pour éliminer la
maladie d'une autre ou d'une sous une
forme ou une autre forme et pousse l'a
prouvé que cette fatalité là où pour
sortir de ce regain de devenu de
soupçons il faut l'information et la
communication
on est tous d'accord que l'afrique ne
peut pas être en marche du processus
scientifique de développement l'afrique
du sud qui compte plus de cent cinquante
neuf victimes alors que au mali nous
nous sommes à la barre de 2000 et la
maladie est en venu là le 25 mars il
n'ya pas de commune mesure
mais tout de même on ne peut pas dire
que le continent africain va rester à
marge mais ces essais cliniques doivent
se faire dans certains certain nombre de
protocoles respectant les candidats en
le faisant en donnant le maximum
d'informations assez à ces sujets là et
ça doit être mené 2-1 catimini et quand
les gens ne sont pas du tout informés
c'est là où est véritablement ça pose
problème et ça donne voix au chapitre à
cette à ce set mais si cela est à cette
idée de le voir qu'on est en train
vraiment de dissimuler la mauvaise
graine ou deux
d'éliminer même une grande partie de la
population africaine c'est tous ces
préjugés qui ont pris le pas et donc on
pourra faire le contraire ou pour faire
des essais cliniques qui sont liés en
même temps à brasilia ou ailleurs ou aux
cours et ou en afrique du sud
et ici en france ou en italie en même
temps sur des des personnes volontaires
ça va se faire par la communication et
par des changes
de combien ma croix alors justement le
laboratoire je pense à un peu senti la
polémique qui en fait c'est justifiant
il a dit justement que ces tests dans
plusieurs zones du globe donc au brésil
et même au royaume uni c'était pour
déterminer l'efficacité du vaccin sur
des populations variées et sur des
endroits variés est ce que c'est un
argument recevable que vous pouvez
entendre c'était le discours qui peut
prospérer quand c'est bien expliqué et
surtout quand c'est le choix et les
cibles sens tu as au prorata du
pourcentage des victimes c'est à dire où
des des malades sur 159 milles victimes
on ne peut pas choisir ou delà d'un
certain nombre de personnes et ces
personnes doivent être informés de 2 du
fait de l'expulser cliniques doivent
avoir toutes les informations et elles
doivent être volontaires et ça doit se
faire en même temps
ailleurs dans le monde et ça doit être
prouvée et donc le danger est de le
faire en catimini de ne pas informer les
populations et et de le prendre sous une
forme de divulgation ou sous une forme
contre-productive vers le continent
le ms a tiré sur la sonnette d'alarmé
par le par rapport aux difficultés du
continent de maintenir la pandémie est
donc il faut même associé la médecine
traditionnelle assez assez et c'est là
où on se souvient du cas de madagascar
avec le co vie de organique qui a aidé à
stabiliser d'autres pays l'ont développé
par la suite au bénin et même au mali
une association qui lutte pour la
sensibilisation ségovie de 19 ans mali
avec la jeune amina taha 100 go qui a
été soigné en son temps par obama comme
une jeune le des on se distingue un peu
partout sur le continent mais ça ne se
fait d'un commun accord avec les
autorités de ces
puis les autorités sanitaires la société
civile
l'implication de la société civile et
voire même la médecine traditionnelle
parce que c'est c'est une question assez
sérieuse la pandémie qui s'est vite ou
par le monde que l'afrique connaît
aujourd'hui 10 et n'est pas cachée mais
la réalité pour faire face à la pandémie
pour traiter cette pandémie là pour
sensibiliser informer lutter
efficacement toutes les couches socio
professionnelles y compris la médecine
traditionnelle doit être impliqué bien
sûr dans cette lutte et au delà de la
prévention même par rapport à la
dérision nous par rapport à la recherche
d'un vaccin
mais c'est qu'on ne peut pas comprendre
on a fixé que joshua engagé avait plu
autant de tests de par le monde et
combien de vaccins sont testés
aujourd'hui et pourquoi vouloir tout de
même quand même tester trouver un vaccin
pour une pandémie alors on n'arrive pas
encore à la guérir cette pandémie la l'a
fait qu'ils les avantages on a tiré sur
la sonnette d'alarmé
le mal a été désigné par là on a dit que
l'afrique va payer le prix cher
tous ces facteurs d'information de
communication ont emmené la population
africaine à se poser des questions à se
mettre sur la défensive et cette
défensive on ne la quitte pas du jour au
lendemain il faut pas souhaiter le
malheur pour que ça vienne en tout cas
le pourcentage de victimes sur le
continent est encore à la traîne par
rapport aux nazis et même par rapport à
l'europe aujourd'hui et si la
stigmatisation de bacon monsieur guy
maria je suis désolé c'est la fin de ce
jt merci en tout cas d'avoir été en
direct sur arte france et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
fondateur de la voix du mali